failed former president donald trump is
now under criminal investigation for
espionage yes violations of the
espionage act my how quickly political
fortunes can turn two weeks ago joe
biden's presidency was very stagnant
record low approval rating donald trump
seemingly coasting to a probable 2024
republican presidential nomination
seemingly unable to be touched and in a
two-week period on the joe biden side
blockbuster jobs report just
extraordinary inflation down
wages up passing the pact act passing
the inflation reduction act
uh and on the other hand
donald trump now subject to an fbi
search warrant executed at his home in
florida
with multiple multiple
different
criminal investigations taking place
let's take it step by step we will get
to possible prison time a little bit
later in the show but to start with the
fbi search warrant has leaked and it
shows that donald trump is under
investigation for potential obstruction
of justice and yes espionage act
violations and we will look at the
details of that trump criminality going
radioactive
a search warrant unsealed friday reveals
that the fbi
is investigating donald trump
for potential violation of the espionage
act and that agents removed classified
documents from the former president's
florida estate earlier this week
a receipt accompanying the search
warrant shows trump possessed documents
including a handwritten note documents
marked with t s sci which is the highest
one of the highest levels of government
classification and another item labeled
info regarding the president of france
the executive grant of clemency for
roger stone was in those items the
warrant shows federal law enforcement
was investigating trump for removal or
destruction of records
obstruction of justice and violating the
espionage act which can encompass crimes
beyond spying such as the refusal to
return national security documents upon
request conviction under the statutes
can result in imprisonment or fines now
one of the things that has also
developed over the weekend
is a seemingly
impossible to unwind
series of claims
about
whether or not the documents were even
at mar-a-lago and it's beyond our
ability to unpack it today and quite
frankly
it's not even the most interesting part
of the story but i should in order to be
thorough mention that endlessly
conflicting claims have been made first
it was there were no documents then it
was the fbi planted the documents then
it was the documents were there but they
were returned by june
so then they must have been planted or
maybe not and then it became yeah the
documents were there and it was
completely fine and legal for the
documents to be there it's a witch-hunt
going after trump for something which
isn't even a crime then it was well i
declassified the documents they were
there but i declassified them even
though there's no evidence that they
were declassified and then trump claimed
well i had a standing order that
anything i take home gets declassified
which is not how declassification works
it is an endless mishmash a gish gallop
a throwing
ketchup for lack of a better term at the
wall
to see what will stick and where we are
at the end is with the unsealed warrant
now the knowledge that part of this
investigation is into trump for possible
violations of the espionage act not
literal spying but a number of crimes
that fall under the general uh umbrella
espionage well so if you are for law and
order
and there is an investigation going on
into
an individual for the violation of
particular laws
what do you say
well if you rand paul you say cancel the
espionage act it's unbelievable let's
talk about that next
you know there's this movement on the
right that claims to be for law and
order they say investigate
let law enforcement do its thing back
the blue law enforcement is good allow
them don't obstruct them don't tamper
with witnesses
rand paul
the republican senator from kentucky
upon learning that donald trump is under
investigation for possible violations of
the espionage act
says oh well we've got to get rid of
that espionage act that's the the
problem is the law
rand paul calls for repeal of espionage
act
amid doj investigation into trump taking
classified documents to mar-a-lago
look at this tweet from rand paul quote
the espionage act was abused from the
beginning
to jail dissenters of world war one
it is long past time to repeal this
egregious affront to the first amendment
repeal the espionage act the future of
freedom foundation
um
you know if this has been a problem rand
since uh world war one
you've had a long time like a hundred
years
during which you could have lobbied for
its repeal and it just so happens that
he only comes out and talks about it
publicly
days after we learn hours in fact after
we learn
that one of the possible crimes that
trump committed is a violation of that
very espionage act rand paul could have
been i don't know how old he is you got
to be about 50 something rand paul could
have been uh talking about the espionage
act for a very long time during his time
as senator when did he become elected
when was rand paul elected senator
um
2010
uh no 2016 anyway i'm not sure sometime
in the 2010s
rand paul for over a decade could have
been saying we must get rid of this
espionage act but it's within hours
of the leaked document indicating trump
is being suspected of violating the
espionage act that he comes out against
it now it's not always the case that
rand paul was so soft on crime you know
republicans claim that they are very
tough on crime and they say we have laws
and we must abide by the laws that's
what it is and sometimes we on the left
say well you know some laws are unjust
some laws are unfair and they say no no
no
you must abide by the law
he wasn't always soft on crime here's
rand paul in sept 2017 with a very
different perspective when it comes to
intelligence and documents and leaks
listen to this susan rice unmasked
anybody we should have a record of it
but it goes beyond even the top echelon
you know we had an nsa uh
security analyst a low level analyst uh
recently caught revealing documents and
we just can't have everybody in the
intelligence community they they have
such power to suck up every bit of every
transmission every communication we ever
made we can't just have them willy-nilly
releasing that to the public so general
flynn's conversation was released that
may not have been up at susan rice she
may have unmasked them but it may well
have been analysts down lower all of
them have to be found and i guarantee
there's a paper or a computer trail of
who released these documents and who
released these conversations
wow wow
he used to say that if you're handling
publicizing releasing leaking moving any
irresponsible actions with classified
documents the individuals doing that
have to be held accountable and every
single one of them should be found
now it's trump and he says repeal the
espionage these people are pathetic and
you know the theme there's no principles
it's what's convenient at the time then
the subject matter
was not convenient so rand paul said
find the leakers prosecute the leakers
all everybody being irresponsible with
these documents anybody who moved the
document to a place it wasn't supposed
to be get all of them
now it's his buddy trump who's doing it
and it's no longer convenient and so now
it's repealed the law under which he
would potentially be charged these
people are pathetic
donald trump faces 33 years in prison
for
just what the doj is investigating him
for
as well as the loss of his ability to
hold public office that is the maximum
possible penalty for donald trump based
on what he is being investigated for uh
there are basically three elements to
this and we're going to look at each of
them you've got the espionage act
if trump is found guilty of violating
the espionage act he would pay face
fines and up to 10 years in prison
now the search warrant
from friday cites 18 us code 793 that's
a part of the espionage act which refers
to the quote gathering transmitting or
losing defense information
some of those doc the documents
reportedly relate to nuclear weapons
so
if charged for that violation trump
could be looking at fines and up to 10
years in prison part two of this
investigation in connection with the fbi
search warrant served at mar-a-lago is
concealment of documents
there we are looking at possible fines
and up to three years in prison the
warrant points to 18 us code 2071 that's
on the quote concealment removal or
mutilation generally and based on that
provision it is illegal to take
government documents it makes it a crime
for anyone to have any federal record in
their possession with the intent to
either conceal or destroy so if charged
there if convicted trump's looking at a
fine or three years in prison but very
importantly and this is why 2071 has
been a big deal over the last few days
if trump is found guilty there he could
be disqualified from holding any public
office in the future could be very
relevant in 2024 and then the third
element here is obstruction of justice
possible fines and up to 20 years in
prison admittedly most people don't get
20 years for obstruction of justice but
that would be 18 us code 1519
that deals with the quote destruction
alteration or falsification of records
in federal investigations and bankruptcy
you are also forbidden from destroying
federal records and this is the highest
potential sentence the 20-year sentence
and um fines are relatively modest now
we are many many steps from anybody
talking about prison time but this is if
we're if the question is being asked
what is the most that we could be
looking at for what the doj is
investigating remember there's the
georgia investigation there's all these
other things forget about that just for
what doj is investigating if trump was
found guilty in all three of these areas
if he got the stiffest sentence and if
the sentences ran uh consecutively
rather than concurrently you could be
looking at 33 years fines and loss of
ability disqualification from holding
public office is it likely that we would
ever get to that the answer is no
but the next step would be
indictment
then you would have trial
plea
if you get guilty verdicts then you have
sentencing appeals okay so this is a
very very long road but at the end of
this path
the absolute maximum would be that the
33 years fines can't run for public
office if you believe trump will ever
see anything like that or even a day
behind uh prison bars
let me know
i still don't see it wanna let everybody
know wednesday august 31st we will be
doing our members only town hall this is
a member benefit that we used to do more
regularly we got away from it we've done
a bunch of regular town halls wednesday
october august 31st at 6 pm eastern 3
p.m pacific we will be doing a members
only town hall opening the phone lines
to our website members if you'd like to
participate among all the other great
member benefits that there are you can
sign up at joinpackman.com
more on that later and in the weeks
upcoming
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
let's continue our coverage of this um
absolutely incredible situation in which
we find ourselves here where a former
president is under criminal
investigation for a whole bunch of
different potential crimes one of the
latest very bizarre
um
it's not even really a side story but
details in what's going on is that
donald trump bizarrely sent a message to
attorney general merrick garland through
intermediaries over the last few days
and it's genuinely unclear at this point
in time whether donald trump is in some
way trying to tamper with or obstruct
the investigation or whether trump is
alluding to the possibility of taking
some kind of a plea deal it's i at this
point i am not sure what the point of
this is
but i will tell you what is known and we
can sort of go from there this was a
paragraph
almost at the bottom of a new york times
article the new york times article is
called trump lawyer told justice
department
that classified material had been
returned now the top line of this about
the returned material
is important and it is relevant and it
also appears to be
untrue and raises one set of questions
and that set of questions is
it seems as though trump's lawyers
really did say
early in june that all of the materials
in question had been returned
obviously the fbi didn't believe that
because ultimately they executed a
search warrant and it does appear as
though the fbi was correct in their
suspicions that not everything had been
returned there's a question as to
whether did trump's lawyers knowingly
lie at that point
were trump's lawyers lied to about the
documents we don't know but that's not
what i want to focus in on today if you
look at this article and you start
scrolling scrolling scrolling all the
way down to almost the very bottom
there is a very interesting there's two
paragraphs that are very interesting and
they read as follows
shortly before mr garland made the
announcement uh recently about
merrick garland made a small statement
about this uh search warrant a person
close to mr trump reached out to a
justice department official to pass
along a message from the former
president to the attorney general
mr trump wanted mr garland to know
that he had been checking in with people
around the country and found them to be
enraged by the search
the message trump wanted conveyed
according to a person familiar with the
exchange was the country is on fire
what can i do to reduce the
heat what can i do to reduce the heat
now this could be interpreted a couple
of different ways
there is more than a couple in fact
there is of course the kind of mob boss
interpretation this would not be new for
trump nice nice business you got here
would really be a shame if something
happened to it right the idea that a lot
of people are angry here merrick garland
a lot of people are angry what can we do
together
so that those people will be less angry
and so one interpretation is these angry
people unless you do something to help
me
might go after you they might go after
your family they might go after fbi
agents and all of those individuals are
receiving death threats all sorts of
security threats we're going to talk
about that in a moment because this is a
this is a group trump is a guy with a
constituency
constituency sounds almost more than it
is which is like a depraved cult
following with a constituency that is
willing to do violence we know that from
january 6. so that could be one
interpretation this is like a mob boss
message to merrick garland the second
one is
would i be
is it possible i could get some kind of
a plea deal could we do something to
make this go away now again it's sort of
more subtle and nuanced than i think
trump is known for but it was through
someone close to trump maybe someone
with slightly better
uh you know capable of more nuance than
donald trump and so that would be what
can we do to calm everything down
maybe you charge me with something minor
and symbolic and i uh plead guilty and
we go from there it's not very much like
trump because trump trump doesn't
apologize and pleading guilty is sort of
like the legal version of an apology it
doesn't mean you actually are remorseful
but in a sense you're admitting you did
something wrong at least to some degree
but of course trump would never actually
do that he would say i agreed to do to
do this i agreed to plead guilty to this
because otherwise the witch hunt would
go on forever it wouldn't allow me to
run all these different things that's
another possibility the third
possibility is this is like a general
tampering message of some kind
that donald trump is just trying to
interfere with
in some way contact the individual at
the top of the organization that is that
is involved in the investigation it's
not really clear now of course trump
could just take responsibility for what
he did and say i did the wrong thing
here it it was unknown unknowingly
i did the wrong thing
and that's it
but that is not what trump does trump
doesn't really take please trump doesn't
apologize trump doesn't admit wrongdoing
so that's what we have as of right now
and it will be a matter of seeing where
these attempted contacts
to merit garland go now next let's talk
about the actual threats to individuals
in law enforcement
trumpest threats
to the fbi including individual agents
involved in the search warrant served at
donald trump's mar-a-lago
and more generally to the justice
department are exploding
we know
that trumpists are willing to do
violence in great numbers we saw it on
january 6th
and
for being about backing the blue
and the thin blue line
and support the police and defend the
police and all of this different stuff
they abandoned that immediately
when it is not convenient we saw it on
january 6th on january 6th all of a
sudden
the police officers
at the capitol were trying to
stop trumpists from getting inside
they were engaging trumpist and trying
to physically prevent them from uh
staying inside
and all of a sudden police weren't the
good guys they were the bad guys they
don't actually care about police the
same that they don't actually care about
the military oh would always defend the
military etc
and yet we saw with the iraq war of
george w bush very willing to just send
our members of the military into harm's
way
for no actual good empirically backed
reason so we're seeing the exact same
thing fbi and dhs warn of increased
threats to law enforcement and
government officials after the
mar-a-lago search
the threats which are occurring
primarily online and across multiple
platforms including social media web
forums video sharing and image boards
were identified by the fbi and
department of homeland security in the
days following the fbi's authorized
seizure of 11 sets of classified
documents from the former president's
home including four sets classified tax
uh top secret according to the search
warrant
um
according to the bulletin the fbi and
dhs have observed an increase in violent
threats posted on social media against
federal officials and facilities
including a threat to place a so-called
dirty bomb in front of the fbi
headquarters and issuing general calls
for civil war and armed rebellion
that includes threats that are specific
in identifying proposed targets tactics
or weaponry
we also have this incident where three
days after the search ricky schiffer jr
wearing a technical vest and armed with
an ar style rifle and nail gun attempted
to forcibly enter the fbi's cincinnati
office and described the standoff it
described the standoff with fbi and law
enforcement officers that ultimately
resulted in schiffer's death
this is obviously expected
i said this on our first stream in in
the when we were streaming the day that
it was learned that this search warrant
was um uh acted on
i said
they are going to go after the fbi and
the doj these people are violent these
people claim to back the blue but that's
only when it's convenient that's when
it's george floyd
that's when it's antifa or black lives
matter
but when it's their own they no longer
back the blue and some of you said david
that's hyperbole that's not going to
happen well it is happening we've
already had an armed guy show up at the
cnn field of cnn fbi they may well show
up at cnn as well the fbi field office
in cincinnati
we are seeing uh the doxing of the
individual fbi agents who participated
in serving the search warrant and they
are it's cause and effect that's all it
is it's a direct result
of the attacks on the verbal attacks on
the fbi law enforcement and the doj
trump did it marjorie taylor green did
it
it's dozens and dozens of republicans
saying defund the fbi
this is a gestapo
the they are actually the criminals and
this is the exact result and it's
actually so bad i mean we know the
script we saw what happened on january
6th it's so bad
that even a fox host is saying trump
should probably make it clear you
shouldn't go after the fbi agents
this is an unbelievable clip though i'm
going to show you an unbelievable clip
here
on fox and friends this morning
steve ducey
um
seemed to be sending a message to donald
trump to stop inciting violence against
the fbi why would steve ducey do this
well because it's not looking very good
for what are obviously trumpist it's not
liberals threatening the fbi as a result
of the fbi executing a search warrant at
mar-a-lago it's trumpists and steve
ducey i guess trying to
make right-wingers not look so violent
and horrible
suggested that it would be great if
trump would call to an end to the
violent rhetoric towards law enforcement
but what's not getting headlines about
this clip is that ducey seems to be
saying really your ire should be
directed at the attorney general merrick
garland i agree that ducey seems to be
saying
we got to stop the violence against the
fbi agents they were just doing their
job
but in this very clip he seems to be
suggesting that it is legitimate
to put your focus on merit garland take
a look at this it's unbelievable that
this is what's happening in this country
we just know that right now given the
fact that there is a suggestion there
are a lot of online very specific
apparently very specific threats against
very specific agents uh at the fbi and
what whatnot it would it would be great
for everybody to tamp down the the
rhetoric against the fbi because the fbi
simply was doing what the doj asked them
to do
the attorney general is the boss of the
guy at the fbi of all the people of the
fbi so
you know with all of these
threats going around
it would ultimately be great if the
former president who has always been a
great supporter of law enforcement well
that's not even really true he's been a
supporter of law enforcement when it's
convenient to his political goals but
okay let's not focus in on that imposed
with a thousand police departments coast
to coast it would be great if he called
for an end to the violent rhetoric
against federal law enforcement and in
particular
the fbi that was just doing their job
all right so so far okay i guess ready
saying call for an end to the violence
but as trey gowdy pointed out last night
uh for you to look at this situation and
think that democrats and republicans
have been treated the same over the last
few years you'd have to be looking at a
different situation right it's the
justice department that's what they're
going the ducey says the fbi agents were
just doing their job as directed by the
doj the doj is really to blame and kill
me jumps in and says and it is and they
are very in a very partisan manner the
doj doesn't treat democrats and
republicans the same a claim for which
there is no evidence yeah i mean leg
irons
talked about that too he said you know
it's interesting that the democrats or
progressives are now worried about
protecting law enforcement when they
weren't
you know years ago during the raids but
no one is for the violence of fbi agents
or
uh you know any of these individuals
that are in law right if you want to
personify that search look at the
attorney general of the united states
mayor garland there it is
guys that
if you want to personify
okay what he's saying is
really the person responsible here is
merrick garland that's where your ire
should be directed oh okay so don't do
the violence against the fbi agents then
just focus in on merrick garland the one
who has staked his entire reputation on
it if there's something if there's not
something really big there he's done
okay
so i mean listen it's
i'll give him credit
the doxing of individual fbi agents who
are just doing their jobs and executing
a legal search warrant with all of the
eyes dotted and t's crossed the approval
of garland the approval of trump's own
fbi director christopher wray
the signature of a judge those are not
the people that we should actually be
holding responsible but that doesn't
mean go after merrick garland and of
course the doj and merrick garland
receiving death threats and everything
over everything you would expect these
trumpists would do they did over the
weekend so you almost had it steve but
now you're saying focus in on garland
these people are truly disgusting and
but to their credit they know their
audience they know their audience wants
blood they know that and he's i guess to
some degree
trying to focus that desire on people
other than the fbi agents we'll have
this clip on our instagram if you want
to see it you can find that at david
pakman show we'll take a quick break and
be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
show a single completely standard
generic democrat
crushed four right wingers on fox news
related to the fbi search warrant served
at trump's mar-a-lago i'm talking about
jessica tarlov i'm like no big jessica
tarlov fan
she's intelligent she's a completely
standard
democratic party apologist not someone
whose political views are super exciting
to me but i have to give her credit she
holds her own when she goes on these fox
news programs she was on a program
called the five
where there are i guess it's like
there's four
sort of hosts and then
a fifth person who they often put in the
middle as you can see here in this
particular episode it was right-wing
bomb thrower dan bongino who was brought
in and every single person on this panel
i believe it's going from left to right
here
degan mcdowell
then it's jessica tarlov dan it's
bongino then i believe that that's dana
perino although there's like 50
different
um
you know blonde news women on fox news
and it's a little zoom zoomed out i
can't tell who that is and then on the
far right is greg gutfeld all right
wingers
the topic is the search warrant served
at mar-a-lago
and they try all of them to use these
very often repeated but factually
incorrect talking points about trump
complied with the subpoena for the
documents but actually he did all these
different things and tarlov is taking it
from all sides and fending it off quite
well i have to tell you president has
had to comply with and why now because
they subpoenaed him in june and he did
not comply
no i'm not she's not making it up
the trump lawyers claimed that trump
complied with the subpoena but the fbi
knew better and they knew they hadn't
gotten the documents back it's sort of
like if you say i am bankrupt that
doesn't mean you are bankrupt you can
claim to be bankrupt i'll go even
further the alex jones example
you can file for bankruptcy that doesn't
actually mean that you are bankrupt it
just means you have you have made a
legal assertion that you are bankrupt
trump's lawyers said we gave you
everything they didn't okay so that
there's there's one aspect and then it
just continues yeah you are he actually
met with him on two third according to
multiple yes
meeting with someone understand the
subterfuge and the distortion
meeting with fbi agents
doesn't mean you complied with the
demand to return all the documents these
are two different things and jessica
tarlov realizes that i actually met with
them on june 3rd according to multiple
yes and then after that james bratt who
was the agent involved in this who does
overseas it was six weeks it was six
weeks since the end of june and that was
okay so then they interrupt her now
degan mcdowell comes in with look at how
look at how slowly they moved it took so
long for them to act it was six weeks it
was six weeks since the end of june and
that was the last communication
if it was so urgent that was so urgent
was there a subpoena ignored by the
trump conversation okay
degan mcdowell is now using another
talking point this is a very common
talking point they're using which is if
this was so urgent if it was so urgent
and of national security consequences
that trump had these documents you know
in his toilet or in his bathroom
wherever he had him at mar-a-lago if it
was so urgent
why did they slow play it so much why
did they allow six weeks to to go by
between the june 3rd meeting
and serving the search warrant this is
one where they want to have it both ways
imagine that the fbi did something
totally different imagine that the fbi
didn't give trump the six weeks they
just went in and went looking for the
documents these very same right wingers
would be saying this is not a way to
treat a former president
they should have done it through lawyers
they should have given the opera given
him the opportunity to return the
documents it's too aggressive to go in
so quickly so do not fall for that
talking point they're saying
the fbi moved so slowly it couldn't
possibly have been of not of security
consequences if the fbi moved quickly
they would have said that's an
inappropriate way to handle an
investigation into a former president
and again jessica tarlov just doing
everything she can to refute this
nonsense subpoena ignored by the trump
they had conversations after the
subpoena multiple conversations
they handed over surveillance tapes just
so again the question is did they comply
with it just because you had
conversations after the date doesn't
mean you did what the subpoena
instructed you to do and then just one
other really funny moment
bongino couldn't help but bring up
hillary clinton and i really like how
jessica tarlov here
looks at her watch and says wow you made
it nine minutes before mentioning
hillary on the democrat side hillary
clinton literally paid a foreign spy
paid a
foreign party as a paragon don't make me
laugh
they can't help themselves
this can't just be about the facts it
has to be about hunter biden's laptop or
when hillary clinton oxycleaned emails
or whatever the case
it can't just be about the facts and
really nice job there done by jessica
tarlov
let's look at another outrageous event
where carrie lake claimed that donald
trump and ron desantis have large
penises this is the place where we are
now in american right-wing politics
these people are listen i i have no
issue
with people work comedians working blue
i have no uh prudish tendencies when it
comes to
any of this sort of stuff
it's just that it's pathetic that this
is what your movement is reduced to
trump now getting applause when he
swears he'll drop an s-bomb or an f-bomb
during some of his uh speeches and the
crap the crowd which is otherwise almost
comatose from trump's boring stories
will get riled up when trump swears and
similarly this is carrie lake she's the
republican nominee for the arizona
gubernatorial race she won her uh
primary a week or two ago
she shows up
and first of all interestingly not
taking sides between trump and desantis
which is a growing element of civil war
within the republican party and she says
she can just tell from their energy
trump's got a large penis and desantis
has one too it
i can't believe this is what's happening
sick
he is gutsy
the guy has bigger
okay
[Applause]
wait let me think about how i want to
wear this my staff always says whatever
you do do not say balls
remember carrie lake is a pro-family
christian
god-fearing candidate this is who the
evangelical's like
so i'm not gonna say it
that guy
[Music]
has a backbone made of steel
i'll tell you what he's got i don't know
if you heard of this but he's got bde
anybody know what that means
ask your kids about it later
i call it big
desantis energy
right
he's got the same kind of bde that
president trump has
so carrie lake very impressed with the
large penis energy
of both trump and desantis and i guess
that's the new christian talking point
it's not who can pretend to be the most
religious it's who can take credit for
the largest genitals the these people
are just deranged it it's they are a
parody of themselves this was by the way
at all over the weekend at a turning
point usa event in phoenix arizona
and um
it it was just riddled with lies all the
way down
a new one ass i could play anything i
played would be filled with lies but one
other aspect speaking of ron desantis
ron desantis showed up and during his
speech he of course condemned the search
warrant being executed at donald trump's
mar-a-lago
but he wrongly claimed that the fbi has
gone after parents at school board
meetings now that hasn't happened i'll
tell you where he's getting this but
listen to this lie from ron desantis i
remember the fbi at merrick garland's
direction
being sick on parents
going to school board meetings
meanwhile when you have a law that
protects supreme court justices is the
fbi out there protecting our
conservative justices no
when you have violations of law where
people are targeting
pregnancy crisis centers are they doing
their job and enforcing the law there no
they're enforcing the law based on who
they like and who they don't like
that is not a republic
well maybe it's a banana republic when
that okay so what on earth is desantis
talking about he says merrick garland
sicked the fbi on parents at school
board meetings and my challenge to you
is to name a single parent that the fbi
arrested and or charged with anything
for going to a school board meeting
that's not what happened
what happened was that there was a memo
released which said
some of these parents
who are showing up at school board
meetings might be making terroristic
threats when parents show up at school
board meetings and threaten all sorts of
different things because of a vaccine
policy or a mask policy or whatever
the doj said consider whether some of
those threats to show up and remember
some of them said i'm going to show up
on monday with guns at the school
the doj correctly said evaluate whether
that counts as a terroristic threat
and it makes absolutely perfect sense
what ron desantis says happened didn't
happen the fbi was not sicked on any
individual parents and none of them were
actually arrested or charged so lies all
the way down of course it is a turning
point usa event
and the truth is this is this is not
going to stop this stuff is going to
continue and we just have to have a
bigger fire hose of truth
to overwhelm their fire hose of lies
that's really the only thing i can think
of that would help us actually deal with
this we're gonna take a quick break
we'll have these clips on our facebook
you can find us on facebook at
facebook.com david pakman show after the
break we will hear from
some republicans their views just random
average republicans their views on
what's going on
and we will also see an incredible
exchange on newsmax between the former
national security adviser john bolton
and newsmax host eric balling on the
subject of foreign policy stay tuned
this is
absolutely incredible video
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live
and stay up to date on other big show
announcements we post daily find us on
reddit twitter instagram facebook
discord and tick talk
arguably the biggest political question
right now in republican world is
will the trump people abandon trump once
and for all because of the fbi search
warrant served at mar-a-lago um there's
the trump legality question of course
which is is he going to get charged is
he going to jail or whatever
um
will he be eligible to run in 2024 but
then there's the would people vote for
him and one of the things that we
learned
is that these maga people
many of whom were never involved in
politics pre-trump
may or may not remain involved in
politics once trump is no longer the
person involved in politics and
you know we maybe have one more election
cycle where where trump will be involved
and so it was with great interest that i
awaited seeing some of exactly these
interviews and clips that we're going to
play for you today
which is
your random maggots
reacting to the fbi search warrant and
unfortunately it's scary and it's insane
this is not merely disaster porn
although it is
it's also about
is there anything for which they would
abandon donald trump now there's been
the infamous i could shoot someone on
fifth avenue and people would still vote
for me and that may be the case and
compared to that this seems relatively
benign in some sense so let's go right
into some of these clips here's one guy
saying this is another bunch of rigor
morse rigor morse all about jealousy
let's be honest robert tassie shared the
same sentiment have you seen the
documents to prove it on a reasonable
doubt that these deaths is a true
statement or is another political bunch
of
rigor morse to make him look even worse
now aside from the fact that rigor morse
is not a word maybe he meant rigamarole
maybe he went some kind of rigor mortis
morse code the sort of morse code of a
dying political dynasty i i don't know
i'm i'm just kidding i don't know what
this guy's talking about but
there is a level of skepticism that
these folks apply
to any criticism of their beloved orange
leader
that they don't apply elsewhere
and he can say anything and they will
defend him and indeed that seems to be
the case here fox news to their credit
they went down to mar-a-lago and they
interviewed protesters and people who
were out rallying for trump and whatever
else
and um it's it's really scary it's quite
frankly it's we have a crisis of
critical thinking in this country take a
look at this what is your view on the
fbi and why they decided to raid uh the
former president's property i think
they're just a mafia you know being uh
ordered by ray an app yeah
it's a mafia ordered by ray ray being
the fbi director
who was chosen by donald trump
and who donald trump expressed unending
confidence in
that's the guy who's running the mafia
tyrae and after this man
our ex-president for so long they're
trying to find any kind of dirt they can
pull up on him this is insane
i never see this happening when i stay
by then has to go to jail
hunter is the one fbi has to go and get
it yeah hunter
go and get hunter now what does hunter
have that the fbi would need to recover
via search warrant i'm not aware of
anything whatsoever and so there's a
combination here of unending devotion to
the cult leader there's what about ism
and we've seen the what about ism has
been heavy what about hillary clinton
well benghazi was investigated
the email stuff was investigated we know
exactly why she wasn't charged with
benghazi she sat under oath and
testified for eight hours there were 11
investigations i believe the number is
these things are
completely and totally different there
is no similarity hunter biden what on
earth does hunter biden have to do with
any of this and then of course they talk
about obama what i don't
obama what obama gate they say but they
can't even explain what that is one more
of these clips this is also fox news
speaking to more people
about uh
the search warrant and everybody's as
confused as you can imagine and that's
basically i mean it's been going on now
for over six years ever since they came
down the escalator they've been after
him
by the way this entire down the
escalator
trump has started using it as a sort of
nostalgic phrase from the moment i came
down the escalator with our beautiful
first lady
uh they've been going after me
that's the thing
now his followers his sycophantic
followers have started to repeat the
whole down the escalator what they the
full story would be
ever since trump came down the escalator
and suggested most mexicans coming over
to the u.s are murderers and rapists
it's been xyz they'll never mention that
extra little part yesterday was the
ultimate we've never seen anything like
that my life i believe that they're
trying to make it so he cannot run i
think they're trying to attack the
american people and they're trying to go
after the person who put us first and
put our american godly values first that
we know what's funny about that put us
first and put godly values first let's
deal with them one by one terms of godly
first trump's not religious trump has
never been religious trump doesn't have
any spiritual beliefs it was all a sham
just like his supposedly anti-abortion
stance this was all contrived and
fabricated in order to justify himself
as a candidate for the republican
nomination because the democratic
primary uh electorate would never have
fallen for trump in the first place
bottom line trump's not religious and
you can look at what's your favorite
bible verse well that's very personal
and when he talked about two corinthians
as if they walk into a bar
uh all it he's not religious but these
folks think this is a godly man but more
importantly he put us first and there's
almost a twinge of sadness with that and
the reason i say sadness is
these people are so duped
trump has spent his entire life as a
privileged rich kid from queens who grew
up in manhattan or from manhattan who
grew up in queens whatever queen's
manhattan
he's been trying to insulate himself
from these folks his entire life the
people that donated the money to him
the people that put him in the white
house
these aren't people that he actually
likes and as we've seen
he only even tolerates them to the
extent that they're useful to him either
financially or more recently in his
political career when they're useful
politically but they've been duped
they've fallen for it it's really
something else godly values first that's
why i believe they're going after him to
intimidate us as americans
okay
in all seriousness
i don't know that even this is enough
for the maggots to bail
it seems that the weekend saw
kind of like a little bit shakier
support and i had the sense come monday
come today
they'll be united they'll either be
united behind trump or united in
abandoning trump
it's still not clear that it's all kind
of shaken out but they have a perfect
way to cut ties with him they could even
say and try to maintain some credibility
we loved his platform in 2016.
he did good things in 2016.
we voted for him in 2020 we even think
he won in 2020 repeat the big lie
but at this point he has become
politically toxic and the republican
party needs to go in a different
direction they don't even really have to
criticize him they have an off-ramp
it doesn't seem as though the magats are
actually willing and ready i'm seeing
hunter this
hillary that obama this and the other
thing
but trump's godly and he's great and all
this different stuff to their own uh uh
to their own detriment at this point in
time
i have an unbelievable video to play for
you a former national security advisor
john bolton going on newsmax
and triggering newsmax host eric balling
newsmax is furious
with bolton
bolton is not a good guy and if anybody
is going to plan to write to me today
and say david you're rehabilitating john
bolton's image
you are praising a war criminal i am not
praising john bolton
the thing about john bolton is he's a
horrible warmongering disgusting neocon
who rightly has assessed that trump is a
lunatic and trump is dangerous and on
that particular issue
he happens to be correct and the degree
to which he triggers eric balling is
unbelievable john bolton has been
correctly saying
we are safer under biden than under
trump
doesn't mean bolton's a democrat doesn't
mean i like bolton doesn't mean he's a
good guy doesn't mean he wasn't one of
the architects of the iraq war it just
means he has correctly assessed that we
are more safe under biden than trump
because trump's completely unhinged
this so triggered eric balling you have
to see this oral could you think that
we're safer now than we were under
president trump when he was willing to
put missiles into syrian air bases with
russians on the base what's going on
here sir he didn't understand because he
didn't understand fundamentally much of
anything about international affairs
true his decisions were not based on a
coherent philosophy well
they weren't based on a coherent foreign
policy philosophy they were based on the
philosophy of
what can i do or say right now that will
benefit me
that that was the to in that sense trump
was adhering to a philosophy he often
miscalculated and it was a depraved
philosophy but bolton's essentially
correct our coherent power we were safer
than we were
he kept under donald trump
world leaders he signed a deal with the
taliban he kept them on their back feet
they didn't know where he was coming
from and that made us safe now there's a
moment here where bolton belly laughs at
balling and that really sends balling
into a tailspin i mean can you he had
president
deal with the taliban withdrawal from
afghanistan
you know what made us less safe is when
biden pulled us out of afghanistan 13
americans died and now this trump
stealing and now the taliban
even
so
even bolton trump's national security
adviser says
what biden did in afghanistan was the
exact same thing trump was going to do
you're hearing it from the horse's mouth
and the trump is still denied they go no
it would have gone so smoothly if it had
been trump overseeing that withdrawal no
it wouldn't have tells us back off don't
kill al-qaeda right
are you out of your mind same thing they
wouldn't have done under donald trump
sir are you out of your mind with
respect of course no ah who who cut the
deal eric
who cut the deal who delivered the deal
no no no trump wanted to what would
trump have done
remember sir no he did not he absolutely
did not he did eric you don't know what
you're talking about
disagrees with you we don't know what
we're talking about trump said leave
twenty five hundred there until we have
a smooth training
he
look he said that after he cut the deal
the deal cut us down to zero that's what
trump wanted he wanted everybody out the
record on that is completely clear over
time biden pulled them out well with
americans still there the best read the
deal eric have you ever read the deal
i'll stop it yeah i know you gotta go
before you're embarrassed even further
okay so listen i really don't like john
bolton but that was very good it really
takes some skill
to make bolton seem like the rational
one in the room or the rational one in
the conversation and again don't write
to me that i'm praising bolton bolton is
a warmongering neoconservative hack but
he specifically pressed some important
points number one
what biden did was the deal trump made
and number two it wouldn't have gone any
differently if it had been trump doing
the pull-out and yes of course we are
generally speaking safer under joe biden
merely because joe biden is a steadier
hand and the best part is bolton just
laughing at him and saying you don't
know what you're talking about sending
balling off uh completely off the rails
at least there are people willing to say
this who are from the former maggot camp
and you know when it comes to bolton
did he know that trump was a lunatic all
along but he was so hungry for the power
of being national security adviser that
he looked the other way did he believe
trump was rational but then had an
awakening i don't even care i think all
of these people are terrible people
whatever brought them to this point it
doesn't even really matter but
anything that can pierce the echo
chamber of a platform as weaponized as
newsmax i think we generally speaking
need to welcome
this is uh a very interesting voicemail
i received our voicemail number of
course is 2192davidp
and you can call any time of day
here's a very specific question
about a story i have not covered and i
don't know that i will take a listen
david it's tommy
i'm coming to you with
tears in my eyes saying sir you must
check out
the 901 calls about lauren bauber's
family they're
perfect absolutely perfect
so
listen there is this story going on
where some 9-1-1 calls i believe it's
from radical repugnant reactionary
republican congresswoman lauren bobert
uh from her home
where her neighbor
called 9-1-1 because i guess bobert's
husband was going completely crazy and
like driving around and running over
people's mailboxes and just generally
acting
in a completely bizarre way
there are 911 calls that are out there
you know i don't have a problem
covering the personal lives of elected
officials
when it is relevant to policy like for
example
when there is a hypocrisy between their
private lives and what they espouse for
example like on gay marriage we've
talked about this or when there are
double standards of different kinds when
we are talking about criminality in
their personal lives or corruption i
have absolutely no problem
the fact that beau bert's personal life
is a mess
and not only did her husband previously
expose himself to people
uh in a bar
all this we and now he's running over
mailboxes the guy seems to really have
some issues their relationship seems to
be
it just doesn't really seem super
relevant to the types of things i
generally cover on the show so i've
opted not to cover the 911 call story i
listened to some of the call over the
weekend
i don't know
i'm curious to hear from people in the
audience
is there a relevance to the story i mean
yes her personal life is out of control
yes i wouldn't trust her to watch my cat
and i don't even have a cat nor do i
even like cats i quite frankly i don't
think much of cats i still if i had one
or was in charge of one wouldn't allow
her to watch the cat all of that is true
i think the woman's a [ __ ] quite
frankly i just don't know that the 911
calls are really relevant to anything
that we talk about on this show but let
me know your thoughts we have a
fantastic bonus show today the situation
with salman rushdie being attacked
is truly truly a disgusting and
disturbing story and i've been a fan of
salman rushdie's for a long time and
we're going to talk about it we're also
going to talk about how
when clinics that offer abortions close
it's also a problem for what's called
gender affirming care and i'll talk to
you about the connection and the sort of
vicious cycle that exists and lastly ron
desantis has an idea
it's a terrible idea his idea is well
the teaching requirements are too rigid
in florida to become a real teacher it's
too strict
so let's figure out a way to allow
veterans with absolutely no teaching
experience or training or degrees to
allow them to teach school
and it's a very very bad idea which is
expected when you're talking about ron
desantis all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show pac-man's a loser
alex jones doesn't like it i know and we
will be doing a members only town hall
on wednesday august 31st which i hope
you will participate in and you can get
access to all of these things the bonus
show
the members only town hall
etc by signing up at
joinpackman.com we will see you on the
bonus show or otherwise back here
tomorrow